sex is the foundation of life it is at
the root of our nature and our lives are
in constant motion towards it every
component of life works to ensure the
survival and advancement of life itself
sex is arguably the most powerful
component as it is the means in which
life perpetuates and fights for the
collective state of existence but what
implications does the force of sex have
on our conscious and human experience of
life as humans we seek and require more
than just physical sexual relationships
we want depth and connection we want
love but while we are all aware of this
and hope to fulfill our conscious goals
of connection and love the biological
survival force of sex works to deprive
us of these goals
this force controls our unconscious
minds and pushes us towards sex with
lots of strangers and away from genuine
connection and intimacy the urgent
curiosity for sexual adventure and
variety is constantly lingering inside
of us prodding for attention so how
should we deal with it
if we break our sexuality down we can
separate its goals into two categories
love and lust love being our conscious
goal and lust being our unconscious
biological one we want to satisfy both
and we can but only when a particular
order and process is followed otherwise
we will constantly run back and forth
between the two and never truly achieve
either lust comes easier than love but
that does not make it more important
lust is hollow when it is not filled by
love lust is needy and greedy it wants
all of our attention and cares for
nothing other than itself when we chase
lust we are forced to neglect love when
we succumb to lust we become attracted
to everyone and as a result not really
anyone we will never find love through
lust we may pretend that we have but we
would be lying to ourselves
lust almost always alludes to feelings
of love but does not always ensure it
the yearning of survival and
reproduction that drives us to want to
have sex with as many people as possible
relies on the circularity of sex
anticipation action pleasure emptiness
repeat
and somewhere within this cycle we are
expecting to find love but it is not
their lusts does not care about love or
the various aspirations of humankind
confusing lust with love is why there is
often so much conflict in relationships
and marriages as humans we are an
overpopulated species so maintaining
existence is no longer the issue at hand
therefore our sexual nature warrants
partially useless results as willful
beings we have the power to examine and
understand this and determine how we
wish to recalibrate our actions to
better fit a balanced and fulfilling
life the real problem humanity is facing
is not population or survival it is lack
of love lack of connection lack of
happiness the only way to love is
through love itself love comes first you
must open yourself up to the love that
you possess it is something within us
all that is beyond objectification by
embracing the unity between yourself and
the rest of the world love blossoms
within you love in a lustful and
romantic sense mayfleet the love in the
sense of connection does not as
chemicals fluctuate in the brain and
factors of the world push and pull you
out of romance
you can still remain constantly with
love when you maintain this your love
will manifest into relationships that
are strong and meaningful
by seeking love through lust you miss
out on love but by seeking lust through
love you become able to profoundly enjoy
both
[Music]